>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Constance Carter: During my
career at the Library of Congress,
I had many adventures, but one
of my favorites was being found
out by the Library of
Congress to work with the staff
of the curator's office
on the botany
of the Lyndon Johnson china service.
There I met the charming and
knowledgeable curator Betty Monkman.
From her days as a
registrar of the White House
in the late 1960's she has learned
the provenance of every painting,
every sculpture, and
every piece of furniture.
Betty will be signing her
book "The White House:
Its Historic Furnishings and
First Families" from 4:30 to 5:30.
Betty introduced me to Bill
Allman, the present curator
of the White House who had been
so helpful to reference librarians
at the Library of Congress.
He can always be counted on to
provide the odd fact or a quote.
And he's stopped us lots
of times from misquoting.
Betty -- Bill has been a
White House staffer since 1976
and was appointed curator in 2002.
He knows the residence
that some of us call it
or the mansion from stem to stern.
And as well as the people who
run it and those who live there.
Allman is the author of
"Official White House China
From the 18th to the 21st Century."
He will be signing
from 4:30 to 5:30 also.
So let's welcome Bill to the podium.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> William Allman: Good
afternoon everybody.
It's really a pleasure to be here.
Book festival is such
a great institution.
And I remember being at the White
House when it got its inception
with you know the instigation from
a First Lady Barbara Busch was in --
instrumental in getting
it started and so.
The White House Historical
Association is our very much beloved
support agency, support
outside authority, non-profit.
And they do a lot of the, the
publishing for the White House.
They were, they were started
by Mrs., by the incentive
of Mrs. Kennedy in 1961 to publish
a guide book The White House
and Historic Guide to
be sold to the public
as they were coming
through on tours.
And little by little it's grown into
five different kinds of guidebooks
and a and a number of other
wonderful historic volumes,
two of which we will
be signing today.
The china book actually didn't start
as a White House Historical
Association project,
it was done by Margaret Klapthor
who was the wonderful curator
at the National Museum of
American History that dealt
with the first lady's hall,
the first lady's gowns,
the china exhibition there,
worked in the 1950's with the --
Mrs. Eisenhower to help improve
the china room at the White House.
So in 1975 she published
the first edition of the
"Official Whitehouse China."
And so the current book is
actually the 3rd edition.
It's been brought up to date
in 2008 and then it was brought
up to date most recently because we
since 2008 have three new
state services of china.
All of which were funded by the
Whitehouse Acquisition Trust
which is a branch of the
Whitehouse Historical Association.
And so earlier this year they came
to, to use with you're the source
of the information and we're
the source of the money
for both the china and
the book and wouldn't --
and we would like to
publish a new edition
and bring everything up to date.
And so it was kind of
a hard moment for me
because Mrs. Klapthor is
you know sort of a mentor
for me and a mentor for Betty.
And we worked with her for many,
many years on the first edition
and then worked on
the second edition.
To be listed as the author
is sort of a misnomer
but it's apparently
stylistically correct for a,
you know the current author
of the most recent additions
to a book written by a
previously deceased author
to get the credit so.
Anyway I'm kicking and screaming
I permitted my name to be put
on the book as somehow
the principle author
but with a very carefully worded
underline that says "based
on previous editions
by Margaret Klapthor,
Betty Monkman and Susan Detweiler."
So the Whitehouse started out
as simply a house and an office.
It became an attraction.
It became a stage.
It remained until 1961
for Mrs. Kennedy to sort
of say I think it should have a
more formalized museum function
to take it from historic site
and attraction into a place
that people could come and
truly learn about the presidents
and the first lady's
and their families.
About American fine arts,
American decorative arts.
The earliest collection within
the Whitehouse would have been the
portraits of the presidents
and first lady's.
That starts with the great standing
portrait of George Washington
that hangs in the east room that
was hanging when the house opened
in 1800 and then was rather
famously saved from the fire of 1814
by first lady Dolly Madison.
But it really remained until the
late 1850's for the government
to say "oh, George
Washington is fine,
but what about the other guys?".
And, and so they, they the
commissioned George Ely
who had painted like portraits of
some of the intervening presidents
and they really started the idea
that they would collect
portraits and, and, and,
and so where as decorative arts
were changing as, as styles changed,
the portraits became a collection.
Early in the 20th Century there
was a wonderful big folio volume
of reproductions of official
portraits of the presidents.
So ever since the, the art owned
by the Whitehouse has been
deemed the official works.
But the second major part
of the collecting a first
for any collection was the china.
That started in 1889 when first
lady Caroline Harrison came
to the Whitehouse.
She was a practical
homemaker form Indianapolis.
She was a practitioner of the
Victorian art of china painting
and actually brought -- had
classes at the Whitehouse with a
with a teacher who instructed
Mrs. Harrison and cabinet members,
and cabinet members daughters and
other friends in china painting.
She was the first president of the
Daughters of the American Revolution
so she was very interested
in American history.
And at the beginning of the Harrison
administration they started the
first 100 years of the presidency.
So it, so it, so it was
a very historic moment
when Mrs. Harrison arrived.
She started going down
into the depths
of the buildings saying
"what's on the shelves."
"What can people tell
me who are on the staff
about what's on the shelves?"
"Is this historic china?"
"Is this you know, what's
interesting about this?"
It started the idea that this was
a way to demonstrate the tastes
of people who had come before.
Because what people don't always
know is that it was perfectly legal
in the 19th century, congress would
say here's some money to move in
and if that's not enough
have a garage sale.
And basically dispose
of those things
that you don't find
fashionable any longer.
Now in the china department many
times I think that was a result
in breakage if there
wasn't enough of a service
to actually continue using it.
Then perhaps the service
would be discarded at auction
or simply being given away.
So the china collection
she started working on it.
There was a very a, a, a famous
journalist named Abby Gunn Baker
who was brought in around the
turn of the century to work
with Mrs. Theodore Roosevelt, Edith.
And in a establishing a the history
of the various services and going
to family members and saying please
donate pieces to the Whitehouse
so we can represent even those
people who are not represented.
There was not always a
formal state china purchase
for every administration.
That's a common misconception
as well
that there's one every time
there's a change of administration.
Many times it was a question
of how recently had the
previous one been acquired,
how fashionable did it remain?
How little hopefully
breakage had occurred.
And so the china collection
was started.
Pieces were pulled out of
storage and placed on exhibit
in the ground floor quarter.
They bought two wonderful Gustav
Stickley arts and crafts bookcases
to be the, the china storage space.
They had just rebuilt
the east terrace.
So now all of the visitors came in
through the east, the new east wing,
past these two china
display cabinets.
And so it was made a formal
exhibition unlike anything else
that the Whitehouse had ever known.
So it -- but there really wasn't
anything written about it other
than what Abby Gunn Baker
did until Mrs. Klapthor
and the first big formal book
on Whitehouse china services.
If you want to know about
some of them I mean the, the,
the have examples of all the state
services now except the Andrew
Jackson in the Whitehouse
china collection.
In many cases these are pieces
that have come back to us
because they got away
either via the auctions.
Occasionally we've been told
presidents would simply give
away china.
We reacquired five dinner plates
form the James K. Polk state china
with the family provenance of
President Lincoln gave them
to Ms. Barber one plate
for every haircut.
And the family had
these five plates.
And they sold them sort of
back to us one at a time
as they needed some
more money I think.
And so -- but we, we've
found things at auction
and so we're very fortunate
in having examples of
the various china's.
The first truly formal service
in the sense of being designed
to be presidential was the dinner
and dessert service ordered
by James Monroe for the rebuilt
Whitehouse after the fire of 1814.
Wonderful shipping vouchers that
described furniture and textiles
and things that were bought
for that refurbishing.
We don't have any pieces
in our collection
of what the dinner service
might have looked like,
but the dessert service was a
wonderful deep red colored border
with five individual
little tiny reserves
where specifically described in the
bill as representing arts, science,
commerce, maritime, and
what they called strength,
which was basically
cannons, and swords,
and guns in the little reserve.
So this china it was
used for a while.
It got away in the mid 19th century.
As far as we can tell it went to
an auction house in Washington
where the auctioneers actually
took a liking to the china
and perhaps didn't
not sell it at all
or bought it you know
from the government.
A great barrel full of it ended up
in the hands of Henry Francis DuPont
at the Winterthur museum up in
Delaware where he had you know
like 80 pieces of this china.
Mostly plates and they were just
kind of stacked up on a sideboard.
They, they, they really
weren't treating it
as any kind of a great acquisition.
The Whitehouse had
one plate on exhibit.
Couldn't persuade Winterthur to
lend any to the Whitehouse partly
because for a long time
they had a prohibition
against lending outside the
boundaries of their museum.
But as a result in the 1980's
we got a call from a member
of the other branch of
the family you know.
So this is -- these pieces
went to DuPont through one side
of the family and here was
the owner of the pieces
in the other side of the family.
Only eight but a wonderful big
ice pail, or ice cream cooler,
baskets, and a few plates.
So he said I think the Whitehouse
deserves some of this service
because Whittier's
hoarding the rest of it.
And so anyhow we got what we think
are the choicer pieces perhaps
because there's more variety
of form in what we have then,
then what Winterthur in fact has.
The Polk china that I mentioned
the, the, the was purchased in 1845.
And all of these were French.
There wasn't any American china
being bought until the 20th century.
The Polk china -- the Monroe china
had a beautiful eagle at the center.
An eagle with the American shield
emblazoned on its, on its chest.
Taken form you know the great seal
of the United States
variations on diplomatic emblems.
There wasn't a presidential
seal codified for a long time.
For the Polk china they
simply put an American shield.
You know the little shield with
the red stripes and the blue canton
up at the top on the edge
of a white dinner service
and then wonderful dessert
service was apple green borders
and each plate was painted
with a with a flower.
And so we have examples
of some of that china.
The Pierce china was
the next at 1853.
It was showed at The Great
Crystal Palace Exhibit
in New York that year.
President Pierce attended.
He was showing two services
by a company that wanted
to make china for the Whitehouse.
There was one with a little shield
at the center and the
letter P on it.
And then there was one that
had an American eagle on it.
Well he picked the
one with the shield
but he very wisely said it's
not for me it's for the nation
and don't put my initial
on it because it belongs
to the people not to
me personally and so.
All of that china disappeared
except one enormous center piece.
It stands about as
tall as this podium.
And has a basket, three
graces standing there holding
up the basket.
Somewhere by the early 20th century
when Abby Gunn Baker was
doing her research, this,
this center piece became the
Dolly Madison china instead
of the Franklin Peirce china.
So they moved it like 40 years
early and seemed to ignore the fact
that well Dolly Madison's
china if it was bought
by the government would have been
destroyed in the fire of 1814
and so it's very unlikely that
it's Dolly Madison's at all.
Which ultimately it was a
more properly identified
with the good help of,
of Margaret Klapthor.
The earliest state service for which
we considered dining is the Lincoln.
It's called the Royal Purple.
It has deep purple border.
An eagle very much like what was
on the Monroe china from 1817.
And a -- so I mean these services
were getting bigger in numbers.
These early services has
lots of serving pieces.
So you would have dozens of
this kind of plate maybe three
or four types of plate but
then you'd have fruit baskets,
and compotes, and ice pails, and
butter dishes and things as part
of the china service rather
than using silver or glass.
And so the Lincoln had an
abundance of these kinds of things.
Three tiered stands, two tiered
stands with custard cups put all
around it for fancy entertaining.
Enormous punch bowls which
we still have both of them.
And so if you were to
-- if a first lady were
to say can we dine
off the Lincoln china,
there are enough dinner plates and
soup plates to actually set a table
for maybe 10 or 12 people.
Usually what happens then is
and the first ladies immediately
understand the wisdom of it is
that you put it on the table and
all the guests come in and you get
to say how beautiful
the Lincoln china is
and the butler takes the
plate away and brings you food
on something that's not so
fragile and so old and so rare.
So the -- but the Lincoln china --
when Mrs. Lincoln left the
Andrew Johnsons' moved in.
There was a huge amount of pilferage
as a result of Mrs. Lincoln being
in the house for more than a month
after her husband's assassination.
The Johnsons' giving her you
know sort of quiet time upstairs.
And the public simply came in
and took what they wanted and --
including cutting the
tassels off the drapes
and taking pieces off the upholstery
and pieces of the china so.
The Johnson' actually
reordered the Lincoln china
and so we have now china that has
a series of differences sometimes
in makers marks, sometimes
in the quality
of the application of the eagle.
In fact the Lincoln ones were
probably an outline was drawn and a,
and a decal was almost put on.
Where the Andrew Johnson pieces
were probably pained by hand
and so there's variations
in the china
but a good bit of it in the house.
The most exotic service ever
ordered was for President
and Mrs. Rutherford B. Hayes.
They hired Theodore Davis who was
an illustrator for Harper's Weekly
and he spent a summer at a
cottage on the New Jersey shore
where he designed a service of
American plants and animals.
Now what the manufacturer
didn't know was
that you know they had priced this
out as you'll give me one design
for a dinner plate and one
design for a soup plate
and we'll make a service.
And Davis comes back with
12 designs for each course.
So and new shapes.
Nothing that was going
to be a mold that,
that poor Haviland actually had.
So they had to retool for
the forms and then they had
to make 12 different
designs for each course.
So for dinner there was a buffalo,
a wild pig, a, a raccoon things
that might be served
for dinner courses.
Soup had frogs and okra plants and
things that might be served for,
for soup and the same thing for
game plates and fish plates.
Ice cream was served on a snowshoe.
And so this is a service where
we have about 500 pieces.
I think it was popular for a while
then it went quickly out of favor
at least by the late 19th century
for being just a wee
bit too Victorian.
But it was the only time the
government ever permitted the,
the vendor the manufacturer to
make it for the public as opposed
to it being exclusive
for the Whitehouse.
But it had separate marks.
So if you have a piece of the
service, it's very beautiful
and its original absolutely period,
but it has a mark on the back
that will say patented
which represents what could
be bought by the public.
But the patented pieces are in many
major museum collections as examples
of the style that was being
set at Whitehouse tables.
So what -- the last
non-American china was ordered
by Theodore Roosevelt in 1903 that
was made at Wedgewood in England.
And then the Wilson's came in --
Theodore Roosevelt had
been presented options
from china factories in Ohio
and West Virginia offering we can
finally make a good American china.
And he still wasn't
convinced so in 1917 Lenox
in Trenton New Jersey became the
first American china manufacturing
company to sell a service
to the White house.
All the 20th century china's
have been much more formal.
A band of color, textured gilt bands
around the rim and the shoulder
and then usually a
variation of some sort
on the presidential
seal at the center.
And the services have
gotten enormously bigger.
They went to -- the
dining room prior
to 1902 seated maybe 40
people 50 people max.
The 1917 service for the
Wilson's was made for 120
because the dining
room was now bigger.
We now find that the
dining room can seat 134.
So basically all the china's
up through Truman were made
for 120 start out short if
there's been no breakage.
And so the, the more modern
services have been made
in increasingly large numbers.
The Johnson's for 216,
the Reagan 220
and then the three
most recent services
which was the reason I'm being
speaking today what I wrote
about in the new addition
of our china book
that represents the Clinton's,
and the Busch, George W. Busch
and then President and Mrs. Obama
that have been ordered for 320.
So that we can have enough to
set dinner in the east room,
dinner in the dining room, dinner
in the dining room plus
some in the parlors.
Not outdoors.
We don't let the good
china go to the tents.
So they rent china for the
outdoor meals almost all the time.
Very occasionally we might let
something go out to be ceremonial.
So these recent china services --
actually when President and Mrs.
Clinton arrived, they did something
that we thought was really very
brilliant and said "we don't want
to order new china, we just want
to supplement one of the old ones."
You know "there's not enough pieces
of the Franklin Roosevelt china
to set all the tables
we need, we like them."
"We like the blue color and we
like the big blue plates form
the Wilson's state service,
how about we just go back to Lenox
and say can we make some more?"
And we thought wow that's
a brilliant idea I mean
so we ordered more.
We had to make some concessions
to the fact they didn't want
to retool some of the 1917, 1918
forms were no longer the same forms
that we -- in their production line.
And then we were very careful
to make them all differently
so every new piece has the original
old mark plus a new Lenox mark
with the date 1994
underneath it and so.
So we thought that was
going to be the end of it.
Then our good friends
at the Whitehouse Historical
Association decided
that for the November 2000, 200th
anniversary of the first occupancy
of the Whitehouse by John and
Abigail Adams that they would want
to sponsor a big gala
historical dinner.
And they suggested maybe we needed a
big historical gala dinner service.
And so suddenly there was
a new china on the horizon.
Mrs. Clinton took a very great
interest in the designing of it.
And so you know very quickly,
originally it was called you know
this is to be the anniversary china.
Maybe it was going to
be the millennial china
because it came in 2000.
But as we expected it pretty quickly
became called the Clinton china.
And so it was unveiled at this
dinner where we were in the midst
of the disputed election
of, of that fall.
You know the hanging chads in,
in Florida and all the things
that went on, the Supreme Courte
decision about awarding votes.
And so here's a dinner where they've
invited all the previous former
first lady's and presidents.
So everyone is in attendance except
for President and Mrs. Reagan
because the president was
already in really bad health.
So Mrs. Johnson, the
Ford's, the Carter's,
the Busch's who's son was
one of the two candidates
who hadn't been decided
and the Clinton's who's vice
president was the other side
of who haven't been decided.
And so it was like
okay is this going
to be a peaceful dinner or not?
You know and what was really
wonderful we got invited,
the staff some of the -- at least
the curator staff got invited
to be dinner guests.
And that nothing but great
things were said about the staff.
That was really the focus
of the, of the dinner.
President Ford, President Carter
they kept saying the Whitehouse is
such a wonderful home.
We had such a good time.
The staff took such good care of us.
You can't believe how
wonderful the staff is.
We're sitting there going
okay this worked out alright.
You know we, we didn't
have any problems
and we actually got you know touted
for all the hard work
people do and so.
But I think that may have
kind of set us on a trend
to possibly having a new
service for every administration.
It's a storage nightmare.
I have to absolutely honest.
And so it was fairly late in
the Busch administration that,
that Mrs. Laura Busch suggested
a china service being made.
I think it starts to be looked
on sort of legacy project.
Something they want to leave behind.
This time around Mrs. Obama looked
much more early into the concept
of wanting a new service
partly to be billed
on the idea they were
getting publicity
for modern taste modern
art abstract art
and could a china service be made
that would you know be more
streamlined a little bit less
historic looking?
But as Mrs. Obama very clearly
said "I want it to be able to mix
and match with all the
rest of the services."
So some of the things that were
talked about in early meetings
with our chefs about oh what is
trending now are square plates.
And it's like square plates are
not going with the round plates
and all the rest of the service.
And so we had to deal
with the issue too.
A chef will tell you if they had
their choice the plate is white.
The food is what needs to show.
The color on the plate is a
distraction from the food.
And it's like well I don't think
an all white service is really what
gets chosen here.
And so then you know you
start working on the thing.
Designs go back and forth
and then suddenly you get a
reelection campaign.
And so things go to
a halt for a while
until you see whether you get
reelected and then you pick
up where you left off and so.
So we have another new service.
These services have been 12
14 pieces per place setting.
320 place settings.
So you're looking at
4,000 pieces per service.
Not so many cups and
saucers anymore.
The traditional service is almost
always had a cream soup cup
and a bullion cup and a
tea cup, demitasse cup
and sometimes a cocktail cup.
Like Mrs. Reagan.
Mrs. Reagan when she came
to the house she knew
exactly what she wanted.
This was the most expeditious
service that was ever ordered
because she had it like -- we
got it early in the second year.
I mean it was all you know --
it was in the works almost the
moment she arrived at the house.
It's got 19 pieces
per place setting.
Cereal bowls, fruit bowl all
the things that if you were here
for a bowl -- let's
talk about desserts.
I think she was already
imagining having desserts
that were only just a couple
of bites but beautifully done
and they needed all
these fancy little bowls.
Some of which I don't
think have ever been
out of their storage
racks but none the less.
We have them if we ever need them.
And so china has kind of evolved,
and evolved, and evolved and so the,
the new book that, that
has just come out is a,
is a very historically minded book.
It's not a all picture book.
Is has wonderful illustrations of
all these wonderful china services.
But there's a lot of technical
detail there about you know bills,
and sizes of pieces and prices of
pieces and quantities and things.
So you know it, it's a read that you
can enjoy a lot of it and maybe some
of it is only truly
for the collector.
Because you have to remember there
are collectors out there because of
that you know 19 century
was legal for china to leave
and so there are people who
have collected and bought and --
Robert McNeal was a big
collector in Philadelphia
and he left his entire
china collection
to the Philadelphia Museum of Art
and they now have a
gallery devoted just
to his presidential
china collection.
So the sort of the parallel
book to this is the one
that Connie mentioned what they
call the Decorative Arts Book.
White House its Historic
furnishings and First Families
which was first published in
2000 as an anniversary project
at the same time as we were working
on the china service
for Mrs. Clinton.
And it's was revised
in 2008 we're up --
brought more up to date in 2008.
That's the most recent edition.
Betty did a fantastic text.
I mean it's just the absolute
perfect you know history of kind
of everything that happened
over time in the Whitehouse
in regards to the decorative arts.
Because you know here's
this collection or portraits
that everybody sees but people
don't know so much about furniture
and the lighting fixtures and
the carpets and the silver
and glassware and things.
And so records are pretty
good on a lot of these things.
Sometimes records disappear
and so you piece it
together as best you can.
We don't own everything
because there were lots
of these sales and things got away.
So when that book was,
was produced my job was
to do the catalogue
section at the back.
And coordinate all the photography
of the objects that we had
that we wanted to use
for illustrations.
And so it's a, it's a -- if I say
so myself it's a really fine book
about the, the subject of
décor in the Whitehouse
and what it tells people
about how things changed.
The Whitehouse wasn't
always 100% up to date
but it was probably a
good example to the,
to the nation of you know people
could come in and see the rooms
and they could admire the choices.
Sometimes there wasn't enough
money in those allocations
and not enough money
made by the garage sales
to actually keep everything
looking neat, trim and pristine.
But usually fairly often there was
a redecoration in the 19th century
so the house was pretty
much up to date.
So when you arrive in 1901
and here's Theodore Roosevelt
who's very much a student
of the colonial revival
and the interest
in 18th and earlier style décor.
Looking at this house going
wonderful 18th century shelf built
between 1792 and 1800.
Very ugly interior based on
all this Victorian stuff.
And so there was the last of the big
public auctions when you know tons
of things were removed including
an enormous Tiffany stained glass
screen that had been installed
in the entrance hall one
of Tiffany's first big commissions.
350 square feet of red, white,
and blue Tiffany glass was
hauled off to the auction.
Sold to man who had a hotel
on the Chesapeake Bay.
Presumably installed in his hotel.
And then when the hotel burned
down in the early 1920's the screen
as far as we know was
melted into oblivion.
So there's a black and white
photograph in existence.
Some color attempts at interpreting
what it might have looked like.
But, but the why is Theodore
Roosevelt did hire McKinley
and White the great
architectural firm.
And they did to the insides of
the Whitehouse let's freeze it.
Let's make it look colonial.
Let's make it look a little bit
empire and stop having it change
with every administration to the
point where the American Institute
of Architects actually sent a
letter saying it should be preserved
untouched forever and ever.
Kind of presuming that there should
be no effort by other first lady's
and presidents to leave
there mark on the house.
And so, but what it means is we
don't really have a 20th century
collection in the decorative arts.
We don't have art deco
furniture or nouveau things
because they simply were only you
know living with these faux antiques
that Theodore Roosevelt bought which
then Mrs. Kennedy took a big step
and said let's leave it at the
periods, let's just take a lot
of the faux antiques out
and put the real thing
in so they public would be
seeing wonderful things.
And she also said we can't
just have portraits we have
to have great artwork
representing landscapes, seascapes,
still lives in the art collection.
And so our art collection has grown.
Our decorative arts
collection has grown.
We still add to the
decorative art collection.
Every fist family buys things
for their private quarters.
Funds are allocated by the congress.
Many times those funds
are now declined in favor
of having other sources of funds
so it's not tax dollars being spent
on making their, their
quarters comfortable for them.
But as a result we inherit a
lot of overstuffed furniture.
Sofas and chairs which
we've been told
by the fire marshal a big
hazard for our storehouse.
And so but they don't become
museum collection right away.
We kind of let them,
let them evolve a while.
Let them be used by multiple
presidents before we say okay we're
going to take every one
of these pieces and,
and add it to the permanent
collection for museum purposes so.
We do not deaccession and so partly
because nobody wants a first lady
to whole sale get rid of the taste
of the preceding first lady's.
And we don't lend to
anyone but the Smithsonian.
And occasionally the
National Archives most often
to the Presidential Library
because there's a natural affinity.
But that was set up early in
Kennedy's time with the idea
that the Whitehouse didn't
need to have everybody asking
to borrow something
from the Whitehouse
and then have 15 things
off the walls
so the public wouldn't
be able to see it and so.
So the deco arts book,
the china book
and we have a wonderful
fine arts book.
Those are kind of the three you know
major publications that have come
from the Whitehouse
Historical Association as sort
of collaborations with our office.
But we also work very closely with
them on a quarterly journal and,
and editing and providing
materials for that.
Symposium that they stage usually
comes with you know some input
from our office about that, that
materials going to be published
or subject matters that are going
to be addressed in symposium.
So it's a, it's a great working
relationship that we have
and we're very happy to have them
as our partners and we're very happy
to have these books available.
And if we see you downstairs, we'll
be happy to sign them for you so.
Please if there's any questions,
I'd be more than happy
to a hear from you.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes ma'am.
>> I understand the concept
of each administration
buying its set of china.
Do they do similar things
with glassware and cutlery?
>> No. We kind of hoped at
one point that maybe one
of those china services would turn
into a new set of glassware instead.
What we're finding is like
everyone can probably attest to,
the luxury trades in
America have gone
down the tubes to a large extent.
Finding American glass
is almostt impossible.
The glassware that Mrs. Kennedy
first ordered in 1961 sorry.
The glassware that she bought you
know was just absolutely plane.
The previous glassware that
had been bought in the 1930's
for Franklin Roosevelt was cut.
And she said I really think
we should have glassware
if you break it no one gets mad
because cut glass is
expensive and hard to replace.
So it was made by a
company in West Virginia.
Then it was -- that company
was bought out and it was made
by another company in West Virginia
and then it was made
by a Company in Ohio.
And it was made by Lenox
and then Lenox closed
up its glass factories
and so, so it's hard.
The flatware we have two
principle services of flatware.
Gilded silver which is actually an
amalgamation of its storage silvers.
So there are forks from the 1890's,
knives from the 1920's,
spoons from the 1950's.
All kind of based on silver
from the Andrew Jackson era
that are often used
for state dinners.
And then there's a silver
service that was provided
in the Ford administration
that we bought from Gorham.
It was a pattern that was called
-- it's called King Charles.
It's actually the King
George pattern
or the Traditional King's pattern.
They renamed it King Charles
because they were selling
it in historic Charleston.
And so, so it's used -- it does
not have Whitehouse written on it.
All the other earlier silvers
including the gilded service is
engraved Presidents House
which is the traditional words
on the silver services.
The old early 19th century name
for it rather than Whitehouse.
So they, they seem to
serve our purposes well.
You know there could be a time what
the first lady would say I wish we
had something that looked more
modern then these very 18th century
flatware services and the same
could be said for the glass.
I know our -- the head of our
food service people didn't'
like Mrs. Kennedy's glass.
By the time we were into the 21st
century said these are glasses
that are too small for
modern drinking and,
and you know champagne should be a
flute and not a tulip and you know.
So he would be all for
a new glass service.
Oh yes?
>> I, I was wondering if you could
talk about the role of symbolism
and helping the first family
either choose a service
from a different administration
for a dinner party
or more permanent furniture
such as President Obama's choice
to use the resolute
desk in his oval office.
>> Well the resolute desk is
a wonderful piece of furniture
that was commissioned by
Queen Victoria to give
to President Rutherford
Hayes in 1880.
It's a great big partner's
kind of desk.
Franklin Roosevelt commissioned a
presidential seal to inset so that
if he were sitting on the other
side you couldn't see his,
his leg braces.
It was used in the private quarters
until President Kennedy
put it in the oval office.
And that made a big, that was a
big symbolic statement bringing
out historic object
and Mrs. Kennedy's work
to be more museum like.
It then traveled as a result of
President Kennedy's assassination.
It was like part of his package
and so it didn't come back
to the Whitehouse until President
Carter asked for it back in 1977.
So it's been used by every
president in the oval office except
for George H. W. Busch who preferred
to use his vice presidential desk
since he had a desk in the West
Wing for continuity, but he used it
in the private residence.
Other things that are symbolic
obviously in this new china
that the presidential seal has made
an appearance on three of the pieces
out of the 11 that are
part of the Obama china.
The traditional places to put
it are on the service plate.
The first thing you
see at the table.
And the dessert plate the last
thing you see at the table.
And the service plate is
in the center you know no
foods actually served on it.
In this case it's also on
the side of the little cup
and saucer that's part
of the last course.
Other services had more eagles.
Mrs. Johnson actually in,
in designing the china that,
that Connie mentioned working on for
the flowers for the dessert plates.
She took the eagle off
the 1817 Monroe china.
She really went back to
a historical president.
Put a very early American version of
the eagle and then put wild flowers
around the, the, the, the
borders of some of the plates
to represent her interest
in the roadside
and the preservation of the land.
And then the 51 different dessert
plates had the state flower for each
of the 50 states and the
District of Columbia so.
So sometimes symbolism
built into the china.
I know with the, the Obama
china there's a certain amount
of streamlining in the design.
And that was designed to
represent there interest
in the abstract and the more modern.
Mrs. Busch, Laura Busch picked
a very nontraditional eagle
for her state china.
It was an inlay in the sideboard in
the family dining room that had a --
sideboard that had
belonged to Daniel Webster
and she just thought you know
it was very much more naive
than a traditional you know defined
by a Harold Dreversen
[phonetic] kind of eagle.
But that's what she wanted so
that's what went on her china so.
And really our office is not
the arbiter of the design.
You know we suggest.
We help with colors and looking
at the other earlier services.
More often than not ours is a
question of quantities, shapes,
storability and things
that go into it.
The china service beyond the
actual what makes it beautiful.
>> Constance Carter: What, what
is served in the cocktail cup?
The only thing I could
possibly think
of is a Tom and Jerry, but usually.
>> No. No.
This is what they call cocktail
cup is a little tiny ramekin.
You've got a ramekin you put the
shrimp in the ramekin whatever.
Then you put the cocktail
sauce in the.
>> Oh.
>> It's not.
>> I of course was
thinking of whiskey.
>> That's not a beverage cup.
>>Okay.
>> But sometimes they're used
for little tiny desserts.
You know crème Brule or
whatever can be put in the,
in the ramekins and things.
Yes sir.
>> So you have any record
of the china that was used
in the personal quarters?
I've got some pieces of a
Haviland china that came
down through my family and the
person they were acquired from said
that it was used by
Theodore Roosevelt.
It's not the official pattern.
And it's not the manufacturer
that you mentioned referenced
that Theodore Roosevelt used.
What's the research approach that
you would use to -- or is there one?
>> Well. Usually its finding
those got any comparable
like the Sagamore Hill the
Theodore Roosevelt home have most
of that same china that
might have been used
in the private quarters
by the family.
A lot of the you know some
for the presidents brought
china for that purpose.
Some of them bought china
while they were in office.
In other cases some of these
like the Woodrow Wilson
and the Franklin Roosevelt china's
you know this is a state dinner
china service that
comes with oatmeal bowls
because it would be used
for serving breakfast just
as well as serving dinner.
There's, there's a much published
story about President Warren Harding
who had many illegal well I guess
poker parties were not illegal
but the drinking of booze at
the poker parties was illegal
under the, the Volstead Act.
But supposedly he gambled a
barrel of Whitehouse china.
But we can't find where
there's a loss in the inventory
to represent that kind of thing.
So maybe it was the family china
that he was willing to give
up because he could buy
some more plausibly.
But if you, you know you
could send us some pictures.
I don't think we'll be the
best source but I would say
if it's really is Theodore
Roosevelt's the best place
to start is Sagamore Hill and see
if by any chance they own
some of the same china.
You know we have some personal
pieces in our collection that came
as a result of first ladiess in
early 20th century asking families
to give something to
represent a president
who would not be otherwise
represented.
So we do have some pieces associated
with Andrew Johnson
and the Garfield's but.
And in some cases we
know they have more
of it wherever they're
institutional home is.
Yes?
>> A little bit back
on the symbolism.
I understand that the Obama china
is based a bit on a earlier china.
I believe the Monroe,
is that correct?
>> Madison.
>> Close.
>> Thank you.
And I've seen them
both and I -- but --
could you go into that a little bit?
>> Sure. The dinner
plate well let's see.
There's 11 pieces.
The, the, the service plate has a
wide gold border which is been true
of the Clinton china and some
plates that the Eisenhower's ordered
that seem to be very presidential.
But with a very narrow ridged
or strident kind of border
to look much more modern and clean
then lot's of frilly Rococo kind
of stuff that's been in
some of the other china's.
Then the dinner plate was
based on a family service
that belonged to the Madison's.
I think it's a very
modern china for 1806.
It's kind of pin wheels and,
and fronds done in black
and white on orange background.
I mean it was a service that was
bought while he was Secretary
of State and may have been used at
the post fire presidential homes
in Washington that Madison lived
in because he didn't get back
into the Whitehouse
before leaving office.
So we have several pieces
of that in the china room
and it drew the attention
of Mrs. Obama
as I think this is a
wonderful decorative element.
And so it was just
done on white on white.
So it's just a, just a
raised element rather
than a, a, a, painted element.
And then the rest of the
service has the blue with the,
the ridges that the strident kind of
border that was derived from a color
which is supposedly the color
of the water off the presidents
home in Kailua in Hawaii.
And so that was a , a throw into
the symbolism of connecting the old
and the traditional with a color
that was unprecedented with kind
of the streamline designing
which was somewhat unprecedented.
And the other interesting
element was is
that you know they're only kind of
two American china makers right now.
Lenox which has closed up all of
its New Jersey factories and moved
to North Carolina as the economy
after they went bankrupt once
and then Pickard out
in Antioch Illinois.
And so Mrs. Obama said
well how about we --
Lenox has made almost all the 20th
century china's for the Whitehouse.
Let's pick Pickard because
they're from our home state.
And so it got a chance to sort of
you know make a statement there
about going a little
further afield and,
and getting something from home.
Yes ma'am?
>> Does you office collaborate
with the Whitehouse
Historical Association
on the Christmas tree ornaments?
>> Not very much.
They've got a great
historian Bill Seal
who has written the definitive two
volume book The Presidents House
who I think is the
principle source of,
of information for
the, the ornament.
Certainly if they have
any kinds of questions
or want any confirmations it's a
very easy two way street coming back
and forth.
And so the ornaments
I don't know how --
if you don't know the
ornaments, they've been going
in chronological order with a few
exceptions where they threw in one
for like the 200th
anniversary of the house
or the 200th anniversary
of the presidency.
And so this year's is
going to be Herbert Hoover.
And so they've already --
it's already been revealed.
So I'm not telling any secrets.
You know it's not like fall
and therefore the Christmas
ornament comes out.
But, but it's a fire
engine because in --
on Christmas eve 1929 while the
Hoovers' were having Christmas
dinner in the state dining
room, staffer walks in
and says Mr. President
the west wing's on fire.
And so they went out on the terrace
and watched the fireman
come and put out the fire.
Staff people went over to the
house and his son went over to try
to save the papers out of his
desk drawers in his office.
One of the staff people had bought
a puppy for his son and put it
in his office and so he
went to rescue the dog
and successfully rescued the dog.
But some of the members of the
dinner party were young children
so in 1930 for Christmas Mrs.
Hoover commissioned toy fire engines
to give to all the children who
had witnessed the west wing fire.
So it's a nice -- you
know everybody it's a toy.
It looks great as a
Christmas ornament you know
with a Christmas tree in the back
of the fire truck and everything.
So I think it's going
to be a big seller.
I'm sure they're hoping so too.
The nice thing we get
you know as, as,
as was mentioned the Whitehouse
Historical Association funds a lot
of our work, acquisitions,
new drapes,
new carpets for public rooms,
the china service and things
so we probably couldn't
do a lot of what we do
without their regular support so.
And the ornaments help
fill up the coffers.
They sell a lot.
Yes ma'am?
>> Is it okay if I
ask a second question?
>> Only up to the time limit.
I have a wrap up so.
>> Okay. On the back of most china
you see the name of the manufacturer
such as Lenox and then
maybe the name
that the china manufacturer
has given it.
What is on the back
of Whitehouse china?
>> Pretty much the same.
It will have the commercial
logo for the manufacturer.
You know what for -- let's say
for Lenox which is traditional.
You know it's an L with a wreath
around it and it will say Lenox made
in America or made in the USA.
It's kind of their tradition.
Then it says the Whitehouse
and the date.
So that's for the usable china.
We also make place
settings for the china room
which says Whitehouse
China Collection.
Separately for the
presidents library
that will say The Barack Obama
Presidential Library Museum.
A place setting for the president
and first lady and a place setting
for the Smithsonian to continue
their long-standing tradition where,
where Margaret Klapthor worked so
hard on creating a china collection
in the, in the Museum
of American History.
So, so those are the
separate marks that go
on what we call the
archival place settings.
Okay I think I have to wrap up.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.